hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
january 11 2021.
can you believe it's already almost
halfway through the first month of a new
year
where's the vaccine
how come the clouds haven't parted yet
um i don't know i don't know what's
going on i thought that they were just
gonna be [ __ ]
you know i thought this vaccine was
gonna come out in 2021
and then the [ __ ] cia the government
and everybody
was going to be shooting us in the neck
with it like when you watch those nature
shows and they're going after like
they shoot wild pigs
just catch a bunch of fatties running
out of food court with no [ __ ]
mask on just shooting them in the neck i
thought that that's what they were gonna
do
i really thought we got it let's make a
big
[ __ ] like we're having a keg party right
let's get a couple of keggers of this
[ __ ] and have people do some [ __ ] keg
stands
slowly but surely trickling out i guess
i don't know what it is but you know i
will tell you this i think covid numbers
are gonna be down in a few weeks because
there was
six [ __ ] nfl football games this
weekend
i watched every one of them and uh
ohio state plays uh
i alabama we ain't got much we got no
[ __ ] time baby
plays alabama coming monday we got it
ain't got no [ __ ] books we got a
football team
the alabama crimson women can't have
rights in our state we got
the alabama crimson tide sorry i had to
get the alabama chatter
you know um going which by the way
i don't know who i'm rooting for in that
game because i love rooting against both
of those teams i like ohio state i like
the i like
the team i'm [ __ ] with you i just
like listening to their fans [ __ ]
whining
all the time non-stop like they're just
like you know when i was a kid
the the [ __ ] [ __ ] that used to drive
me up the wall was was the [ __ ] notre
dame fans when they used to act like
nobody there did steroids everybody said
the you know the lou holt's years yeah
yeah your prayers you good yeah when you
gain all that goody goody [ __ ]
horseshit
you all know they were out there [ __ ]
shooting heroin and banging horse okay
like it's a college football program
okay maybe not heroin okay
whatever none of this none of this is
back by any sort of information they
just it just bugged me maybe i didn't
like where my life was
and i didn't lean this this [ __ ]
little old guy telling me how to live my
life
when i'm trying to watch a goddamn guy i
think that's what it was
it's my apologies gonna be a lot of
apologies
on the podcast this week all right but
anyway let's get to the uh
there's something about watching nick
saban losing his [ __ ] that i just love
to see because it it i don't know what
it is
i do that at least he's doing it for a
great reason he wants to win a football
game and continuing being you know him
and his wife being mr and mrs alabama
you know you think they're walking
around playing for barbecue was the last
time they [ __ ] paid for barbecue in
that state you know
well i guess if they're down near auburn
yeah but when's he going down there
um all right i've talked myself into a
corner as far as like i don't even know
i mean usually i don't know what i'm
talking about but now now this is this
is a
an especially um tough corner i've
talked myself into but i
think
oh man i love the sec
i also like the big ten i don't know who
to root for i'm just gonna i'm just
psyched that there's gonna
the two powerhouse teams are gonna be
there i was breaking ohio state's balls
a little bit only having to play six
games but they lit they mopped the
[ __ ] floor with clemson so
um it ain't their fault there was there
was covid so
they obviously deserve to be there so
um come on bill pick someone
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go ohio state
for jay lawhead rose bowl tailgate
legend
back when we used to go to the rose bowl
now there's covid
um i'm gonna root
i'm gonna root for them despite how much
i like
smartass wilson's barbecue and alabama
i'm going to root for i'm going to root
for a house date there i said it but
here's the thing
this is why i think covert cases are
going to go down because i think
everybody was just [ __ ] inside
everybody was inside i'm sure there was
a lot of fights with the wives
you know unless you married a gamer you
know who's sitting there right with you
you know [ __ ] cheering it on but i
watched every single game there's
a few games i saw like i didn't see as
much of like the saints
bears game i didn't get to see a lot of
that because i had to go do some stuff
with some other parents and kids and
stuff you know
you know parents from my daughter's
school
um so we sort of a social thing in the
park which was kind of nice because i
had watched so much football at that
point i did need to get outside
so let's start what kind of world are we
living in
where the buffalo bills beat the new
england patriots twice
sweep them in the regular season and
then go
on to win the division and win their
playoff game
i'll tell you what kind of world the
kind of world where the cleveland browns
beat the pittsburgh steelers in the
playoffs
back to back weeks and they beat him in
[ __ ] pittsburgh
um let's start with the bills bills beat
the colts if i can i'm gonna
i don't know the [ __ ] names here um i
just know that they won the goddamn game
i was really thinking that guy heinz was
gonna be more of a problem
for you know the colts uh running back
i just feel like he's uh
has the potential to become a superstar
um
and uh you know once again the stupid
[ __ ] analytics
why the colts don't kick two field goals
in the first quarter um first half i
don't know why they don't do i don't
know what the [ __ ] it is
i don't know what it is i was watching
the
[ __ ] brown steelers and they go well
you know if they went for two there then
they only would have been down
if they get it if they get it
jesus [ __ ] christ what is the
analytics versus kicking the next
of kicking a [ __ ] field goal versus
going for a two-point conversion
i don't know i don't know but you know
me i don't like change
i'm like most people most old people i
don't like change
which is why my i got an apology coming
up
in the future so the bills win that game
it's great to see
you know and uh
then i the most dominant performance i
saw
all weekend was the los angeles rams
beating the seattle seahawks i mean they
just i've they just [ __ ] won
every single aspect of that game i
couldn't believe it i mean i sat down
you know i like watching the seahawks
i just thought that they were gonna uh
you know i thought it'd be tight in the
first half and then seattle would pull
away that's what i thought they just
they kicked their [ __ ] ass is the
only way to say it
on the offensive line the defensive line
the corners
running passing special teams they just
[ __ ] had their foot on their neck
their neck from the beginning of the
game to the end
total domination
um and then tom brady
the tb the tom brady buccaneers
tb now stands for tom brady not tampa
bay the tom brady
buccaneers my team that i'm rooting for
with gronkowski antonio brown
uh beat the team from washington
it's a closer game than a lot of people
thought um
and then that ravens titans game jesus
christ lamar jackson just showing why
he's the mvp of the league the most
exciting amazing play i saw of the
entire [ __ ]
what i saw because definitely i was
dipping in and out with the kids
was uh that 40-yard like it looked like
he was going to get sacked
then it was like is he going to get a
first down and all of a sudden he's 40
[ __ ] yards later he scores a
touchdown
amazing amazing uh
performance and the ravens game plan
you got to give it up to him all right
we're sticking everybody up on the line
we're going to take henry out of this
game
we're going to let ryan tannehill have
to beat us
and he did not saints beat the bears i
missed most of that game because i was
doing the parents thing and then i just
watched the brown steelers
which was just a [ __ ] bizarre game
like the steelers just i don't know what
was going on
hiking the ball over the head throwing
[ __ ] pics and doing just they did
everything they could to lose the game
in the first quarter
um and then somehow still ben
roethlisberger
throws for 500 yards i would love to see
stats
before they opened up the game like how
many times somebody threw
a quarterback through for 500 yards and
lost the game let's look that up
shall we now i know there was a part of
a weird you know
maybe the browns played a little lighter
defense when they were up
the amount that they were up but you got
to give it up baker mayfield
huh got to give it up to that guy how
many [ __ ] quarterbacks have come into
cleveland
not done been able to get going i mean
you just
your career was done before it even
started and that guy
has led them to uh to the playoffs
in a road victory the cleveland browns
first road victory since 1969 since we
walked on the [ __ ] moon allegedly
um i think we did
i would think why why the [ __ ] would you
make that [ __ ] up
you know so you just what brag to other
countries
well bill that's that's what the
conspiracy theory is okay
um qb's
throwing 500
yards and losing
brady is the first qb to lose a game
with 500 yards
three touchdowns oh that must have been
oh that was the super bowl
against uh was that the eagles it was
the eagle game he threw 500 [ __ ]
yards
i remember that game i was sitting there
i was talking to my buddy i don't know
who's gonna win this [ __ ] game but
nobody on defense of either team should
get a [ __ ] ring
um and the punters should get a
participation trophy
came out there like two three times um
big ben threw over 500 [ __ ] yards
and uh you know probably threw for 80
yards
if you count his interceptions another
80 yards i should say uh just
unbelievable huge [ __ ] win for
cleveland
for cleveland and uh i can't imagine
um it was funny when they said this is
probably the biggest victory
in cleveland brown history or something
like that it's just like uh they
they won championships back in the day
paul brown
you kidding me i think that their
biggest victory was when they won their
first nfl title
in 1950 coming over what from what
people said was the inferior
all-american football league and they
came in the first year they won the
[ __ ] title after winning all four
they won four in a row all-american
football league championships 46 47 48
and
and then the nfl's like oh it's an
inferior league all right now it's
collapsing we'll take a couple of your
teams we'll show you how football's
played
and the brett cleveland browns game the
old right there fred it legitimized what
the [ __ ] happened in the aaa
the all-american football league and
then also they they literally
changed the paul brown changed the
[ __ ] game he's the original
bill belichick he proceeded vince
lombardi all of these [ __ ] guys he's
the guy
and they came up with the west coast
offense with bill walsh
uh in cincinnati i mean ohio is
football so it was so bad that cleveland
has been been bad for this [ __ ] long
um it's great it's [ __ ] it's fantastic
um having said that i hope that's not
ben roethlisberger's
last game when he was just sitting there
on the bench it made me said
um just a [ __ ] amazing competitor you
know
and despite you know how many
interceptions and [ __ ] i mean they
weren't out some of them were tipped and
stuff
it's like the guy still threw over 500
yards and had cleveland brown fans
[ __ ] their pants with 12
12 minutes ago and at one point they
were up 28 nothing all right
so there you go there you go all right
let's talk about my day
the best part of waking up
um i had like just a great dad weekend
you know my daughter had her first week
of school and um
so i was i really really missed her you
know she's my buddy right so we just
we just spent both days like hanging in
the garage
you know she's got a scooter you know
riding bikes
you know playing drums she's really
getting you know
understood like getting good at drums
you know just
kid good you know and uh she now she now
she says
she right before she starts playing
drums i'll have guitar and she has the
drums she'll go dada
let's jam that's the coolest thing ever
um but i owe an apology to coaster bikes
i'm starting to see that uh exactly what
they said
that training wheels inhibit
um and delay and they don't really teach
anything they just it's just somebody
holding you up the whole [ __ ] time
um the coaster bike i now get it
i now get it and uh at first my daughter
was just fighting it and fighting and
said she didn't want to do it and they
don't get it
because once they've ridden a tricycle
they want to pedal and if now if they
got a scooter
like my daughter is like blazing fast on
the scooter
and is just one with that thing it's
like crazy she's like looking back
making a turn smiling at me gliding and
then occasionally
swiping her foot on the ground to keep
her momentum going it's like
yeah me and my mother-in-law were just
watching her just looking at each other
shaking her head's going look she's got
this down
so the big thing with the coaster bike
is i think once you get them to push
with both feet at the same time and then
glide a little bit
and then they start to get it um and she
started doing that and then i got her on
her
her christmas bicycle that has the
pedals and everything and now
she's like pedaling it's got handbrake
so it's weird when she stops pedaling
then it goes backwards
if she gets like confused and [ __ ] so
um sorry i'm yawning i'm doing this at
the end of the day i really apologize i
just have a million [ __ ] things to do
tomorrow
and uh i'll be on uh jimmy fallon's
tonight's show
i almost said the jimmy fallon shows how
tired him the tonight show with jimmy
fallon
jimmy fallon didn't buy the tonight show
it's the tonight show with jimmy fallon
sorry
uh looking forward to that i've known
jimmy
since 1996. i've also known him for a
quarter of a century it's crazy so i
always have fun when i go on that show
so tune in if you can um so i gotta
knock this thing out
tonight and there's just been so much
funny [ __ ]
in like the news and everything but
anyways let's get back to being like a
dad i just did all of that
uh you know i was giving my daughter
you know just going up and down the
driveway in my old truck
and uh she loves steering it and all of
that so i was getting her to go what
what is that
right there and she's like uh that's the
choke mike that's right what are these
that's the wipers what are those those
are the lights so i'm just getting all
of that down because i told you one of
these days
she gets tall enough it's three on the
tree i'm gonna teach her how to drive it
um you know i think that's
that's a really like big thing you know
teaching your kids how to do [ __ ]
let the teachers teach them how to read
and write and do all that crap and then
you teach them how to do [ __ ]
other [ __ ] kind of rounds them out you
know what i mean
um and then also you really i don't know
i think it's big to remember
like what it was like to be there age
one of the things that i hated
the most was you know
when you started running out of your
favorite clothes
and then you go to your tier two clothes
and then you just had the
those clothes that you just never wanted
to wear but you just had to if your mom
didn't have time to do laundry or
anything
and you know i had a couple days like
going to school and just what i had on i
mean i was getting this
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] kicked out of me
before i even got in the goddamn school
or whatever just getting hazed and stuff
it was just one of those deals right
so uh tonight before i was doing the
podcast
i i did the kids laundry
and my wife's like what are you doing
starting laundry now and i was just like
well you know she's going to school
tomorrow and
i always i told her like i always hated
that when i was a kid
you know women out there like oh
anytime you care women just like
i've learned so much about women in like
the last six weeks
and like i i was doing everything
[ __ ] wrong it's hilarious
they really are not that difficult to
live with as crazy as that is
i mean they're difficult they're selfish
and all that [ __ ] we all know that
you know you buy them a bunch of shiny
[ __ ] and they'll like it for a month and
then a month later they want the next
shiny thing especially one of those
[ __ ] kardashians wears it right
but i mean just as far as like sort of
just keeping it going along you know all
you gotta do is take them out to lunch
every four or five days take them out to
lunch
take them for a drive you just go just
go do some silly [ __ ] that they like to
do
they love it they love it you know and
then like
they never really do any of the silly
[ __ ] you want to do right but
conversely they're not in a bad mood so
like that's that's how it works
you know in the male female dynamic like
the best you're gonna get as a guy
is that she's not mad at you you know
but women can really you know
you know they get a lot of
get you to participate in a lot of [ __ ]
that you wouldn't participate in
you know i just i don't know i hope i'm
explaining this right like that
if they're not into sports they're not
come down just [ __ ] watch sports just
to keep you in a good mood
because they don't need to do that all
they need to do is just [ __ ] leave
you alone that's the thing about just
[ __ ] leave us alone and you're golden
i'm at this chick she's [ __ ] great
she's cool as [ __ ]
she's cool as [ __ ] means she doesn't
[ __ ] break my balls
she's not nagging me that's all you have
isn't that funny
all women have to do is not nag a guy
and they're good guy's gonna be in a
good mood right unless you
you know dating a [ __ ] you know you know
some [ __ ] guy all right and with
women though all you have to do
you have to do [ __ ] with them
so you know like mostly you're going to
lose
in the exchange but like uh
you know if you love the person you're
with you want to keep them just keep
them around you just do some [ __ ] with
them
it keeps them in this really like nice
place
and i just started doing that and my
wife was always cool now she's just like
ridiculously cool
um and i'm really learning [ __ ] cause it
was two times she [ __ ] pissed me off
you know she pissed me off to today and
i and i just [ __ ]
was just like i don't i don't want it
it's not worth it it's not worth it i
just breathed my way through it i
thought about it
it was a comment she made and the way i
interpreted it probably was [ __ ]
wrong
you know we'd done all of this [ __ ] and
i had like
i don't want to get into my day whatever
she had to go and do a bunch of [ __ ] so
i was like double dad
duty right and then doing laundry
cleaning up the kitchen doing all of
this [ __ ] running out to get dinner all
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] and we come home
after all of this crap right
well i met the parents as we're pulling
to the driver she's like
oh god my workout today just hit me and
in my head i'm thinking like of course
it did
of course it just hit you because you
realize we're going into the house now
and it's time to give the kids baths
so you're waiting for me to take the
bait which of course i did
um that's how i read it that's how i
read it and i [ __ ] and then i was
just like you know what dude maybe she
is just tired she's also breastfeeding
the kid's literally sucking the life out
of her don't be a [ __ ] and i and i
didn't and i did all the [ __ ]
and you know what right before i came
out and did the podcast she came up
kissed me on the cheek and said i really
appreciated all the stuff you did and
that's
it that's it so i'm really realizing the
same way i went off on those people that
had the coaster bikes
all these years i've been you know just
fighting dying on every [ __ ] hill
like so many
times like there's not even a hill there
it's just my own
[ __ ] up brain um with grass on it
um all right let's uh i i got
i got a tease cause cosmo magazine slash
i gotta give them props you know it's
really hard to have a magazine now
you know so what you gotta do like
rolling stone they figured it out every
three days they put out the top
[ __ ] bass players of all time and
then they [ __ ] have them
just so people can read it and be like
you gotta be kidding me
flea is only 26 right so they can lose
their [ __ ]
genius right so what is cosmo gonna do
the top
[ __ ] 20 hundred top hundred uh uh
chicks with the eating disorders we put
on the cover no no they can't do that
they go the other way they go the other
way
they put a bunch of overweight chicks on
the [ __ ]
magazine cover and they're like
this is healthy right
just to get people to go what the [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
they're using these big girls
to sell their [ __ ] magazine
and i don't think that they believe i
don't even think they believe what
they're saying
it's just a total [ __ ] it's
low-hanging fruit
as far as like it's like shock jock [ __ ]
they're just doing that
everybody knows that's not healthy
that's not good for you if you don't
believe me like i'm 52 years old most of
my overweight friends are dead
it i mean it is what it is here's the
thing cosmo
are you gonna do the where are they now
follow up to that in [ __ ] 20 years i
don't think you're gonna
i don't think you're gonna um
i don't know what the purpose of that i
totally understand not being mean to
people that are overweight i
i do get that but to [ __ ] sit there
and say that
i mean that's literally like somebody
what if someone was drinking to that
level
this is healthy some guy face down
in his own [ __ ] yak i mean i don't
this is it i don't buy it i don't buy it
i think that's just total marketing i
don't think that their their
their heart is behind it that's that's
what's saying that and then i saw some
other [ __ ] and this is the only reason
why i see
you know this [ __ ] is because i'm
one of the biggest hypocrites you're
ever going to [ __ ] meet your life
um i really enjoyed like when i was
waiting for the football to come on you
know my daughter was bugging me she
likes that's
this [ __ ] thing ryan's world where's
this little kid
he plays with toys with his parents and
he makes like as i don't know how much
money this kid he's making like the same
money johnny carson made a year
or dave letterman a year and he
generates like
nine figures in toy sales so he's not
underpaid
actually i think he's kind of getting
[ __ ] i mean if he's if he's generating
250 million dollars in sales and he only
gets 30 million i mean
i don't know can't give the kid 50.
um so my daughter always wants to watch
it right
and that show ryan's world is definitely
um one of those shows like back in the
day like teletubbies i remember my
friends
when they had kids teletubbies was big
and it was one of those things that kids
were just like
would look at it and couldn't stop
looking at it and adults were like i
can't there's nothing here for me
um you know where if you watch like bugs
bunny there's like
it's just funny and then there's also
jokes in there for adults same thing
like the genius of sesame street right
so with ryan's world the only thing
there for the adult is i'm just watching
the parents
and i am amazed at their energy
and everything that they're doing when
it's just like
and i know i know they're making money
too but it's just like
they turned in they turned the
exhausting job of
of of being a parent
just like where's that like when we were
in like the park you know what i mean
you know i'm racing my daughter let's i
know like she was a little shy around
the other kid so i was just going like
all right let's uh you know get her out
there so i was like hey
i'll race you to the tree and you know
she loves doing that and you might get
set and she'd think it's hilarious if
she takes off early
and you know that was that was good for
about three four trees and then you know
15 minutes later she wants to keep doing
it and it's just like
[ __ ] knees bugging me you know
so i'm watching these parrots i'm like
jesus christ the the
i mean it's not really physically hard
what it is is it's i would think just
mentally to be playing kids games
like that and they're shooting it so you
got to do like different takes i would
just think it was exhausting so that's
the only thing i'm getting out of it i
just sort of watched the parents going
like
their energy level is incredible um
so anyway she wants to watch it and
i kind of lied to her i did lie to her
the other day she wanted to watch it i
said i can't watch it
she goes why so cause ryan's asleep
she's like how's he asleep in the tv dad
i was like oh god you always ask the
best questions
she asked one time we watching tv she
goes how come they're wearing masks
inside the tv
[Music]
meaning basically how they can't breathe
on us why do they need to wear masks i
had to try to explain to her that
this is showing people sitting next to
each other i don't know
they're not in the tv um
so anyway so i finally just said listen
ryan never goes to sleep it's recorded
i just daddy can't watch that show all
the time and she said why not i go
ah
you know daddy doesn't always like that
show
i've decided i'm not going to sugarcoat
[ __ ] i mean i'm not going to be a total
[ __ ] but it's just like
like daddy can only take so much of that
show like i watch bugs bunny with you
all day long i can deal with ryan for
about [ __ ]
25 minutes so anyway
um so she's bugging me to put the show
on and i'm waiting for the nfl
pregame show to come on so i caught the
end of that george stephanopoulos show
and they're all talking about this [ __ ]
about we're gonna [ __ ] impeach trump
and all this [ __ ] i'm like i'm [ __ ]
impeach the guy he's got like [ __ ] 10
days left what are we doing here
and then like oh if we don't do it then
we're setting the president that
you know because now now the big thing
is that that [ __ ] went down at the
capitol
the big thing now is to put it all on
donald trump like he was the only
[ __ ] guy
that got people
of a certain mentality to that level
of frenzy that they would do some [ __ ]
like that and
um so now everybody
is just walking away from him and i
really feel like
uh i wish that on that show that they
would examine do you think that 24-hour
news networks
that aren't really presenting the news
as much as they're presenting their
opinion about the news
clearly biased to one side or the other
what that what that is done um
so i don't know it was just funny
watching that chris christie guy getting
on there
and just talking about you know i wanted
to be i wanted somebody to be like well
you were in bed with this guy so let me
ask you a question
where did this guy lose you at what
point did you start going like you know
i don't know
was it you know it seemed like you were
all about this guy until he kicked you
to the curb i don't follow politics a
lot but i know he was in bed with the
guy for a little bit
and once he sort of kicked him to the
curb
you know and then he still kept his
mouth shut for the whole thing and now
that he's lost the election all these
people in that lady on fox news
wagging her finger and yelling at those
people that did whatever the [ __ ] they
did there at the capitol because i've
still not
quite watched all of that i have to be
honest with you that
really looked like i did enough morning
radio
to know that when you do morning radio
and you have a live event like
that's what shows up
[Music]
no matter how smart your show is smart
people have [ __ ] to do
they're not showing up in a [ __ ]
parking lot
to watch a radio show but lunatics
there's something about radio
that it would just you know i remember
back in the day when we used
and i was on that [ __ ] amazing show
the opiate anthony show
the amount of really smart people that i
would run into on the street
that were like hey man i'm a big fan of
the show you know and they would really
could talk comedy and
in like you know just really smart
people
but then when there would be a live
event
you know i mean think about it it's like
it's the middle of the work week who the
[ __ ] is gonna be there
you these were like [ __ ] lunatics so
i mean as
pissed off as people are
you know that that person didn't win
who's got the [ __ ] time
to go to washington dc for a protest
forget about
to start following somebody dressed like
a bison into the goddamn place
i don't understand it um
anyway so now all of a sudden they're
like can can uh
mike pence invoked the 25th amendment
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is the 25th
amendment
so i started looking at it and all it
basically said was if the president died
or became
incapacitated that he becomes president
so like
i couldn't you know i sort of skim read
it i don't understand i thought like
doesn't that happen in in the house not
the white house the other house the
house that they broke all the windows on
there
the bigger house the more impressive
house you know
i always like the capitol building more
than the white house you know what i
mean
i mean half the [ __ ] people on the
real housewives those [ __ ] botox
[ __ ] have a bigger house in the white
house
um it's not bigger than the capitol
though you got to give it up to the
capitol right
um i don't know i'm talking about people
here i don't know what's going on with
this [ __ ] but um
it is i think it's kind of good though
that people are finally speaking up
going like all right
everybody settle the [ __ ] down what's
going on here and i and i hope
that everybody has learned
including just you know people who
aren't on those channels that
like when you sit there and [ __ ] with
people
online you don't know who you're [ __ ]
with like i i've kind of learned that
through doing what i do like when people
[ __ ] on me
you know send me emails and trash me and
all that stuff like i just ignore it
because you have no idea what's on the
other end
of that [ __ ] email unless it's
funny you know like a lot of people like
on twitter i'll go but if they talk
sports and [ __ ] i go back and forth i
think that stuff's fun but when somebody
really comes at you
you know and it's so internalized
whatever the [ __ ]
joke was that you did you're just like
all right this person seems like you
know they had a lot of bad [ __ ] happen
to the like i i don't need to be
[ __ ] with so i just you know i let
him have their victory go ahead you win
trash me
it's all you i read it i heard what you
said
and i'm not writing back um so
that's what i'm hoping in 2021
i'm hoping that you know this this 80
year old guy with a facelift who seems
to be a warmonger
doesn't start another war in the middle
east and
uh i hope that somehow we can sort of uh
i don't know i mean look what teslas are
doing to all of these [ __ ]
loud-ass gas-guzzling cars i mean
they're just blowing them off the line
and all these [ __ ] idiots not [ __ ]
needs all these people who have invested
in a gas combustion engine all they can
say is
well you know it doesn't really you know
it beats it up to about 80 miles an hour
and then it kind of taps out
yeah 80 miles an hour
okay what's the speed limit out there
the car is [ __ ] incredible
the [ __ ] car is incredible
um so
you know if you're going north of 80
miles an hour you're an [ __ ] if
you're doing that in public just go to a
track
and go see what your car can do because
you know i'm not saying a gas combustion
engine is 100 wrong
i'm just saying it's one of the main
reasons isn't that why we're over there
in the middle east
am i crazy my outsider
all right i don't know let's just get
the [ __ ] out of this subject i watched a
new netflix uh
series uh is it lupa l-u-p-i-n this new
french
um netflix series there's only five
episodes the first one i loved watched
it last night with my wife
um i was able to kind of keep up with
the french pretty good
because it's it's not like hardcore
dialogue
um it's not like that's really like
uh i tried to watch uh call my agent
and uh they talk really fast
uh vupale trovite
um
i i have a difficult time and then like
i feel like that like
this lupine series i'll be able to maybe
pick up more on and then i can then i
can watch
because i feel like call my agent is
sort of their version of like the office
or whatever
so it's very like snarky quick dialogue
maybe i don't know what it is but i i
i love a god i can't [ __ ] keep up
with it
um so anyway
there we go did i handle all of that
[ __ ] i'm trying to bring people together
people here all right i'm not trying to
cause any [ __ ] arguments
and you know i thought that miami heat
thing that i did the last podcast was
funny most people thought it was funny
but there was a couple people jesus
christ this one [ __ ] guy
he's just like after 10 years
of something like he decided because of
that joke
um that he was no longer going to
watch my comedy or follow my podcast and
he felt the need
that he had to issue a statement on my
twitter account which was just the
funniest [ __ ] i
didn't have the heart to tell the guy i
didn't even know you were following me
you know i get it if you didn't like it
you go [ __ ] go listen to another
podcast
why do i have to [ __ ] like how
[ __ ] up your own ass
are you did you really think i was gonna
be sitting there like wait a minute
what happened to that guy that i don't
know oh thank god he issued a statement
now i know that this guy who i didn't
even know was following my podcast has
decided to [ __ ] leave
i swear to god the internet has turned
so many [ __ ] just
joe six-pack people they they act like
people in my business who have their own
[ __ ] tv show
um well obviously he's gonna be
devastated
i have to i need closure
all right let's um let's
read a little bit of the uh let's do a
little advertising here all right
let's go right out of the gate right out
of the gate
um what do we got here
um oh okay we're gonna go with oh
here we go new reed here it's herbs
cider herbs [ __ ] cider herb cider
c-i-d-e-r herbscider.com
all right award-winning hard cider
produced by tim
herb alexander drummer of primus
uh it's made from organic apples it's
gluten free all ciders have
low to no sugars i mean come on man
these are the cold winter months
gotta love a hard cider uh you can
follow them on instagram at
herb cider h-e-r-b-s-c-i-d-e-r
order online and get it delivered right
to your door you don't even need your
pants on
um by the way uh
tim sent me some of that stuff about a
year and a half two years ago
and i unfortunately had already quit
drinking and i brought it down to the
comedy store
and i handed it out to some comics and
for weeks they were coming up to me
going dude who made that [ __ ]
where can i get some more of that stuff
so proof's in the pudding
all right herb cider dot com
made by the great tim herb alexander
a drummer oh this can be fun to read
these he's got so many rs and all of
this [ __ ]
um all right let's get to the other [ __ ]
here what do i got here what do we got
here
lollipop lollipop
talk about how much you love soda i lo i
do love soda i love orange soda
fanta and i love the [ __ ] uh
uh i love root beer i'm not into diet
soda
[ __ ] diet soda um says talk about how
much you love soda slash diet soda or
used to love soda but haven't had it in
years
no i've been you know since i quit
drinking i actually uh you know i
partake
i partake there late at night because i
don't want my daughter seeing me smoking
the last of my cigars before i quit
again
because she's always like dad why are
you blowing smoke
so i gotta i gotta stop doing that but i
drink a root beer with it
so anyways obviously these guys lollipop
they make [ __ ] soda let's get to it
here
okay there's a new kind of soda that
tastes amazing but it's actually good
for you
uh we've converted a ton of customers
over from diet coke
by the way if you want to know about
diet coke talk to [ __ ] dean del rey
he went out on a date with some chick he
said that used to [ __ ] make that [ __ ]
i don't know it was that was one of
these dinosaurs diet coke i don't get
[ __ ] sued by these people wait it's
the internet can't get sued
um she said i worked for one of the big
cola companies and we make she saw him
drinking it said just to let you know
when we make that stuff the concoction
for that they make us wear hazmat suits
so enter ollie pop
all right a new kind of soda that tastes
amazing
then it's actually good for you i think
this is going to be a revolution
in uh drinking soda who doesn't like to
have pop
right everybody likes it um i actually
tried their root beer
i gotta tell i'm gonna be dead honestly
it was weird for two sips and then i got
used to it
and afterwards i didn't feel like [ __ ]
like oh god why did i do that
um i only had the root beer and it i it
gets a big thumbs up for me
it tastes just like the sodas i grew up
with without the spoonfuls of sugar and
artificial green it doesn't it tastes a
little bit different
but it's almost like when you've been
eating the [ __ ] version for a long time
it takes you a second like i used to
pour a bunch of sugar on my
cereal and it took a while after when i
stopped doing that now i actually like
tasting the cereal
is that a good example i hope whatever
it's the first [ __ ] reek
break my balls here uh they have
delicious flavors like
vintage cola classic root beer that's
the one i had orange squeezed cherry
vanilla
and strawberry vanilla talk about your
favorite my favorite so bar is the
uh the root beer i'll tell you about the
other ones because i'm smoking another
stick
after this uh how do i say that in
french
i'm gonna go smoke a stick
uh humi
un club or something like that i think
that's a stogy
uh talk about your favorite flavor and
why you're loving it
i love it because it tastes like root
beer and it doesn't make me a fat [ __ ]
ninety percent of americans consume more
than the third the usda's daily
recommended sugar intake
30 grams sweetened beverages like soda
are the leading source of added sugars
in the american diet
and isn't also sugar like a carcinogen
unlike other sodas that are full of
sugar corn syrup and artificial
ingredients
like aspartame lollipop is yeah and
they're starting to see that that stuff
creates plaque in your brain i think
is made with natural ingredients that
are actually good for you they are so
confident that you will love their
product that they offered 100 money back
guarantee
for orders placed through their website
we worked out an exclusive deal for the
monday morning podcast listeners
received 20
off plus free shipping on their
best-selling variety pack
this is a great way to try out all their
delicious flavor to claim this deal go
to drink ollie pop
dot com slash bur or use the code bird
check out that's
drink d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p
dot com slash burr it's a great way to
keep drinking soda and [ __ ] stay in
shape
um speaking of staying in shape we got
butcher box everybody
all right this year you're gonna eat
better and spend less time and money at
the grocery store
thanks to butcher box you should do it i
have been butcher box is the meat
delivery subscription that gives me
more time for what matters most jerking
off and playing drums
sorry each month they
they send a box by the highest quality
meat
speaking of meat not spanking it this is
eating it
uh quality meat for a better price than
the grocery store which gives me more
time to spend cooking and sharing
delicious meals with the family and
friends i do love doing that luckily
today's sponsor butcher box believes
everyone deserves high quality humanely
sourced meat before they murder it
talk about how easy it is that but they
[ __ ] said it right to you you throw
it in the freezer
and you feel like eating it later on
that night you take it out you stick it
on the counter right you sit down you
watch sportscenter
play a couple of video games whatever
the hell your poison is and you come
back out and you throw it in the oven
and you're great
all right my favorite thing is the uh
the goddamn uh
heritage breed pork all right start year
off right with up to 10 pounds of free
meat
for a limited time butcher box is
offering new members their ultimate keto
bundle
when you sign up today that's right lose
the weight
uh that includes one pork butt two
pounds of ground beef and three pounds
of bone-in chicken thighs for free
and the first box by going to
butcherbox.com each box has 9 to 11
pounds of meats that's enough for 24
individual meals
unless you're a gluttonous son of a
[ __ ] all right it's packed fresh
shipped frozen vacuum sealed
i can't say enough about it it's
fantastic
um all right what do we got left here
let's plow through these here right
policy genius everybody it's a new year
finally so let's try to start it off
right if trying to save some extra cash
is on your mind think about
uh reshopping think about reshopping
your home
and auto sharing and auto insurance
rates with policy genius you can save it
to 1055 dollars per year
with the help from their licensed
experts think about what you could do
with that money you save
you can invest it buy a tv get your
house doomsday ready
put it in a savings account buy a
chicken outfit and walk down the street
and freak people out whatever you want
to do
possibilities are endless here's how it
works first head to policygenius.com and
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property
uh then policy genius does the rest
they'll compare rates uh from over 30
top insurers from progressive to
nationwide is on your side
to find the lowest quotes their license
experts will look
at all ways to maximize your savings
including bundling your home and auto
policies
if policy genius finds a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll get you switched for free
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star five-star rating
across
1600 reviewers on trustpilot and google
just uh head to policygenius.com
to get started right now policy genius
when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right all right oh
look who hey
my bookie how the [ __ ] you doing huh nba
basketball
nfl playoffs nhl hockey comes out next
[ __ ] week what do you want what are
we doing here
it's my bookie it's that time of year
when divisions are decided championships
are crowned and legends are born it's
time for
nfl playoffs you've waited and watched
all year as your team rose to the top or
fell to the bottom
but now it's your turn to win big you
heard the name just about everywhere my
bookie
my bookie they're the industry's leading
online sportsbook and casino and it's
not hard to understand why with
thousands of lines to bet on
all your favorite sports nfl nba college
ball check check check and check
mma and soccer they got all the latest
odds period
take advantage of my bookies prop
builder and live in game betting where
every single run throw and touchdown is
another chance for you to put cash in
your pocket
it's crazy visit their mobile friendly
website today and get your deposit
matched
halfway up to a thousand bucks you put a
thousand bucks in they're gonna match it
with 500.
they're going to half match it uh just
use the promo code
burr b-u-r-rr when you make your first
deposit the best part is
the best part is [ __ ] they simp
it's simple and variety of ways to
deposit instantly
including credit card bank transfer
bitcoin
and more god damn uh
whether you're at home or on jesus
christ i'd love to go to their casino
you see every [ __ ] currency out there
you think you know james bond movie
uh whether you're at home or on the go
on or on your laptop or on your phone
it's not too late to make your new
year's resolution a resolution to get
paid
bet win and get paid at my bookie
promo code bur all right lastly but not
leastly stamps.com everybody
you know one thing we learned in 201
2020 the internet is even more awesome
than we thought
groceries online movies online doctor
visits online and of course
going to the post office online with
stamps.com stamps.com allows businesses
to do all of their mailing and shipping
right from their computer no need to
leave their home or office
or home office stamps.com has saved
small businesses all over the country
thousands of hours and tons of money and
now you can too
stamps.com you get the services of the
post office and ups right
on your computer plus big discounts on
mailing and shipping rates
you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been the sponsoring the show for
over nine years
and if you haven't tried it what the
[ __ ] are you waiting for stamps.com
brings the services of the u.s postal
service and ups
right to your dealer whether you are uh
whether
wherever you are sorry stamps.com my
[ __ ] that whole lineup stamp style
company's the service of the us postal
service and ups right to your computer
wherever you are stamps.com is the must
is must have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
out invoices an online seller
shipping out orders or even a giant
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps.com can handle all of that
[ __ ] with these
simply use you can simply use your
computer to print official us posters 24
7 for any letter any package any class
of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready just schedule a pickup or drop
it off it's that simple with stamps.com
you get five cents off every first class
stamp
and go and get uh and up to 40 percent
off priority mail
and up to 62 off ups shipping rates not
to mention it's a fraction of the cost
of those expensive postage meters so
make 2021 the year you stop wasting time
going to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with my promo code
burr you get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long-term
commitments
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone to top the homepage and
type in burr b-u-r-r
that's stamps.com promo code burr
stamps.com
never go to the post office again all
right [ __ ]
it was paying for it there was no
advertising on the last one and all of a
sudden there's a whole bunch in this
[ __ ] thing okay
let's get through the goddamn people
writing in here all right
re flat earth this is a flat earther
everybody
he says hey pasty uh last time i wrote
in about flat earth i tried to explain a
motive for it
which was basic oh cause i was like what
is the motive for telling people
that it's round when it's really flat
he said which i tried to explain the
motive for it which was basically along
the lines of
there was a lot of money to be made in
the idea of
space you and your guests i don't
remember who it was who he was
said that it would be impossible to get
100 of the governments on the same page
with this big of a lie
which would make sense if more than
three country countries have been to
space
oh jesus christ america russia and china
are the only countries
to go to space so you'd only need the
three of the most
powerful governments to be in on the lie
so i think it's more probable than you
and your friend made it out to be
hey buddy you don't need to go to space
to know the world is round you just get
in a [ __ ] boat and you start
sailing west and you keep going till you
get back to your house again
dude get on that boat get on that
[ __ ] boat go to antarctica go find
the [ __ ] ice wall take some [ __ ]
pictures and then i'll believe you
um the best part of waking up
is knowing the earth is round
um hollow earth
dear billy vemm as in
jewel oh dear billy vern as in jewel
vern
i don't know what that means if you
think that flat
think flat earth is crazy you should
look into hollow earth
apparently there's a hole in the arctic
that leads to the center of the earth
apparently al gore is one of the few
people who has received permission
to go to this arctic gate there are
great
artists illustrations to give if you
give it a google
seems legit to me
i don't does that make the earth hollow
if there's a hole that goes to the
center of it
let me ask you this if you take a
[ __ ] nail and you hammer it into the
center of an apple
and then you take the nail out is the
apple now hollow
that just means there's a [ __ ] hole
in the center of the earth i don't give
a [ __ ] about that as long as i don't
fall into it
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is all of this
about who gives a [ __ ]
if it's round flat or hollow i don't
give a [ __ ] is it still spinning
is the sun coming up tomorrow good i got
other [ __ ] to [ __ ] worry about
jesus you guys are like bird watchers
with like dirt
[Laughter]
it's just a [ __ ] obscure hobby go go
[ __ ] do it
um by the way i saw a [ __ ] clip of a
snake that got stuck in a spider web and
a black widow was like
thing was just sitting there i don't
know if it paralyzed it with its poison
or what
it was [ __ ] nuts i can't believe it
was real how the [ __ ] did a snake get
all the way up into that thing
um maybe he just watched
that michael jordan thing come fly with
me and he got all amped up
decided to [ __ ] you know i mean
that's you know what
that's a [ __ ] pixar movie right there
a snake that wants legs
so sick of just scurrying around the
ground
you know one of his best friends is a
centipede
there's a couple of songs in there and
some message about [ __ ]
live and let live i don't know
snake just learns in the end everybody
with legs gets stuck in something but
because it's a [ __ ]
snake it can go down the hole that leads
to the center of the earth and the snake
proves that the earth is hollow
and that's the end of the movie there
you go i don't know you just [ __ ]
have famous people do the voices i know
you guys figure it out all right
chinese food
rec what does that mean chinese food
wreck
i don't know what that means all right
dear mr i hope this is somebody from
china
oh chinese food recommendations
oh my god
what a good [ __ ] all right so i was
asking my chinese listeners
if i have any to give me the heads up
saying you don't have to tell me where
your favorite place is to go
you don't have to ruin it by telling a
white guy where it is just give me your
second favorite place
where you go so here we go uh dear mr
what's going on it's bill burr and it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
belly button um i am your
i am of your fan from china
how wild is that what's up man how you
doing are you in bed right now
well you're listening i'm thinking you
in bed as i'm writing this sick
actually no they're like [ __ ] 14
hours ahead of us
he's probably staring at the clock right
now going how the [ __ ] am i gonna get
through another day of this goddamn job
all right i am your fan from china i
enjoy listening to your podcast when i
walk around the river in my city
river i often laughed hard when i
listened to it
like when you did the impression of your
daughter dada
you're the greatest in the world as a
mom of an eight-year-old i can sense
your inner happiness and smartness
isn't that nice and you still like me
because i assumed you were a guy
um since you want to know which chinese
restaurant to go in la for authentic
chinese food i searched online and asked
my relatives in l.a in l.a what a good
[ __ ]
thank you so here comes my
recommendations
i know you hate bad internet information
but we do trust
the restaurant recommendation app i o i
use and also i ask my relatives that's
the big one
in la all right now am i going to share
these with everybody else
yes of course i'm going to all right she
has given me two
all right number one is din tai
fang d-i-n-t-a-i-f-e-n-g
and then she has the the uh
chinese alphabet characters there to
spell it out which is also really cool
you know be [ __ ] hilarious is if
i had that tattoo on me because that's
like a big thing out here right
there was a big thing in like the 90s
into the 2000s of people who didn't
speak chinese getting chinese
lettering on them and these guys were
just [ __ ] with them writing like uh
you know egg roll and duck sauce or
whatever um anyway it's more like a
imagine if i read that and my i thought
i had courage strength and honor
in chinese on my forearm and it turns
out i had din tai fang
just the name of a restaurant they used
my forum for advertising they never paid
me that'd be [ __ ] hilarious
um it's more like a fusion of chinese
food so you can
find a huge variety of food there like
cantonese food northern chinese food
southern chinese food etc it's a chain
store too
i don't know if i like that people can
find it in singapore
thailand and other places i have to say
it's way better than panda express
the must try one is juicy pork
dumpling all right it's in torrance
california
on hawthorne boulevard
good deal all right number two is
sichuan expression s-i-c-h-u-a-n i
apologize
to all chinese people with this brutal
pronunciation i'm trying here
expression i think sichuan food
excels in all chinese cuisines it's like
the cajun food in louisiana
it holds a reputation for its huge
variety of seasonings used
as each dish requires different cooking
methods as the saying goes
one dish with one flavor with 100 dishes
comes
100 flavors sichuan food is well known
for its hot and spicy flavor i'm
in though it may sport sweet and sour
flavors too the most commonly used
spices are the five
fragrances which consist of fennel
pepper
any seed cinnamon and clove
chili and sichuan pepper obviously i was
born in sichuan but i have been
to many different places in china so i
know lots of people over the country
love the food if you can bear spicy food
all right if you cannot have spicy food
you can try
kung pao chicken
isn't that just like a [ __ ] regular
are you [ __ ] with me here
twice cooked pork and don't forget the
snack it's the fried rice
all right i need to expand extend my
gratitude to you because
i know more about nfl and college
football
thank you for being the sports culture
ambassador
your podcast lights my day and is also a
super great way for me to practice my
listening
look at that she's learning in english
listening to my dumb ass
by the way i i realize that your
listeners
are a man probably the other day but i
as a woman feel super happy
that i enjoy myself when i listen to you
ramble about daily life stuff and sports
i even wonder what heritage pork was
once
look forward to your super bowl podcast
go
[ __ ] yourself best wishes ying hey yang
thank you for listening and thank you
for the recommendations
i'm going to try that spicy one
i'm i'm gonna actually try both of them
um god knows i got the time man
pandemic continues all right advice
different relationship with woke sister
oh difficult relationship with woke's
sister
all right now is that it's sister
s-i-s-t-e-r so i mean i feel like that's
a relative if it was s-i-s-t-a
then then that'll be a different thing
right all right hey belt
i'm a recent big fan and lady listener
look at this two ladies in a row
my boyfriend introduced me to you we
watched paper tiger
and had my politic and i had my
political defenses up he saw me making
faces and just told me to wait and hear
you up
i opened my mind and really heard what
you were saying it was hilarious you
brought my defenses down and taught me a
lot
now you're fa you're my favorite
comedian i listen to every podcast look
at that
look at that i brought you into my world
of ignorance
um i have a difficult relationship with
my sister because
although she seems to be doing better
she's 20 years old and has already dealt
with so much depression
that sucks however it just keeps getting
harder to keep a relatively good
relationship with her yeah it's
exhausting
it's exhausting to have a relative
that's depressed
to try to [ __ ] pull him up off the
mat every day
is exhausting you know as much as you
want to help them out you know
there are times where you're just like
[ __ ] anyway however it just keeps
getting harder and harder to keep a
relatively good relationship with her um
i've always tried to help her as much as
i can as a sister but she sulks a lot
and really feels sorry for herself it
affects our relationship
because she insists on keeping us
parentheses me and her other sister at a
distance to protect us
in quotes she doesn't realize how much
of a cop-out that is
we all have struggles well it just seems
like she's being there's a difference
between actually being depressed
and just being a mopey [ __ ] i would
think
with my lack of any sort of psychology
degree uh
she thinks hers are worse than anyone's
she's also glued to her phone when we
hang out and can't hold a conversation
with me despite my many attempts
is she depressed or is she self-involved
that's the question for me at this point
anyways it seems like she spends all of
her time on social media so it seems
fitting
with all that with all this that she
would fall victim to the white women
hijacked
wope movement would also be if she's on
social media all the time
that's also they say it really is bad if
you're a depressed person
anyway this is part of the reason i
don't feel comfortable around her i
can't be myself i feel like i have to
walk on eggshells
what is she gonna do cancel you from the
[ __ ] thanksgiving table
you gotta go the other way i would just
start acting extra ignorant
um which i think is the solution to all
of this all of these overly sensitive
[ __ ] people
you just you just act like more of an
[ __ ] it's it truly is that is the
balance of nature
if you're gonna get overly sensitive i'm
gonna be overly annoying
if you're gonna [ __ ] be a good [ __ ]
i'll meet you in the middle
um all right i feel like i have to walk
on eggshells around her she'll jump on
me for saying something wrong on
christmas i was showing my parents
comedians in cars getting coffee
my mom wanted to watch the dave
chappelle episode and my sister blew up
at us about how we made some
violently transphobic comments and went
to her room
she came out remembering that it was
christmas and we had to get through
dinner
i haven't talked to her since but she's
being fake nice at dinner
and i couldn't stand it hey you know
what sometimes you got to let people
just go through their [ __ ]
and let her walk out and then what you
do is you watch the comedians in the car
with dave chappelle
and you act you just laugh extra loud
you laugh like [ __ ] dinero in cape
fear when he was at the movies
um since my problem with her is twofold
i don't know how to approach it i'm
tired of trying to meet her halfway
she calls me and acts like she wants to
hang out but she but when she does
she doesn't do anything it's like she's
not even there how do i explain to her
how i feel without her getting defensive
should i even try to talk to her at all
where should i start anything helps
thank you for reading i appreciate your
perspective
yeah you are completely being held
hostage by her emotions
all right this person doesn't sound
depressed to me they just sound like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um this is what i would try but you know
if she really is depressed i don't want
you to
say something [ __ ] up to her and god
forbid she does something crazy so what
i would do
is i just would stop [ __ ] reaching
out to her as much
and um when you hang around there if she
wants to be a mopey [ __ ]
that is not your [ __ ] problem
when you were a kid and you laid in bed
and you were like what is my dream in
life
is my dream in life to cheer up mopey
[ __ ]
trying to figure out why they're mopey
even though i was in a good [ __ ] mood
[ __ ] her if you want to watch comedians
and cars with dave chappelle
you watch that [ __ ] she doesn't want it
she must go to room fine let her go to
the room
and when she comes out screaming and
yelling and be like look i want to watch
this
i didn't tell you not to go to your room
i didn't try to make you stay here yeah
i don't know she's only 20. maybe she'll
grow out of it hopefully you guys will
laugh about it someday but i think
it's really not about her at this point
i need i think you need to sort of
reclaim your own happiness
and when you're around people even if
they're relatives and they don't make
you happy then you know it
you need to [ __ ] protect yourself all
right
would you go hang out with somebody fun
have a good time
um oh my god i would break her balls and
be like
little sister you know what i love about
you you remind me why
i love my friends so much because
they're not you
no he can't be that mean that's what i
would do i i would i would
i think you're you're you've sort of
lost yourself in this
and i think it's from what you've told
me she's just being
she's being a little controlling um
and if she wants to hang out she's gonna
sit and look at her phone and she's
she's being a douche
i would just look at me you know you can
look at your phone at home what the [ __ ]
you come over here for drinking my
goddamn
booze um but know that i'm a douche
so there is that take all and i have no
degree in anything so
good luck to you all right
i got to be honest i read that whole
thing and i felt bad for you i didn't
feel bad for her at all
[ __ ] idiot stormy storming down the
goddamn hall
all right 1966 dash the trap
all right my name's sid spelt cyd
um i am a woman three in a row
and a computer programmer love your
podcasts i too
turn to it to get me through these
uncertain times
like a junkie well thank you for
listening he's she says my movie
recommendation
is the 1966 movie the trap with oliver
reed hard to find though
i bet i could find it online it's got to
be somewhere and also
uh you like them animal prey shows
you gotta see the show i was pray
specifically season two
episode three about the hippo and the
tour guide oh my god this is people who
almost got eaten
the whole i was praised series about
people being turned into prey by wild
animals
better than a horror movie okay that's
all for now i can't say it i was raised
not to curse
so i can only vocalize alone to my
computer screen
gfy i respect that nice classy person
uh the trap i will definitely check that
out well thank you guys for writing in
love hearing from the ladies
um
love hearing from people around the
world all of that [ __ ] love it love
hearing from sports fans the whole
goddamn thing so thank you guys for
listening
i hope you guys uh are gonna tune in and
watch the uh
ohio state alabama game tomorrow and uh
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves i'll check
in on you on thursday
congratulations to everybody who made
the playoffs and congratulations
i mean who the [ __ ] would have thought
the buffalo bills and the cleveland
browns
even a year and a half two years ago
would both make the playoffs the same
year
and win the first [ __ ] round that's
so awesome and i'm really happy for all
of the fans they waited so
long and uh like i said
the los angeles rams i don't know what
the [ __ ] that was but
that looked like when bill bill
belichick had the patriots
performing at the top level it was
amazing and to see
groff come in you know just recently
uh operated on thumb gutsy gutsy [ __ ]
performance
it was just great it was great i love
seeing
a uh
i don't know they're just the x's and
o's of that and how everybody did their
job and shut down an incredibly talented
team like the seattle seahawks and um
you know what's his face there flanders
[ __ ] am i spacing on his name oh sneaky
pete pete carroll like
he really got that defense where they
needed to be they were letting up all
kinds of points early in the year i
thought he did an
unbelievable job this year coaching he's
such a great coach
and i was looking forward to watching
them deep into the playoffs and then
they ran
into that la team just god damn did they
shut them down it was [ __ ] it was as
a football fan it was a pleasure
to watch so that's it and also i don't
know
it's a pats fan first time in [ __ ]
two decades my team isn't in it
since the matt castle year i guess um so
once in
20 years uh it was kind of fun to just
sort of sit there and root for some good
football
and i definitely got it and the nfl
adding the team
in all of those games that was the [ __ ]
so good on them that's it
i'll talk to you guys thursday